two high schools on opposite sides of
the country are safe this morning after
police apprehended students allegedly
threatening attacks a fifteen-year-old
in South Portland Maine was arrested
yesterday police say he posted on social
media that he wanted to shoot up the
school in Everett Washington an 18 year
old now faces three felony charges
joshua o'connor appeared before a judge
wednesday after his arrest for allegedly
planning a school shooting his
grandmother learned about it by reading
his journal went ahead and tipped off
police tony dick opal is here with the
disturbing details tony good morning
good morning disturbing is definitely
the right word Joshua's grandmother
Cathy told authorities she found a
semi-automatic rifle hidden in her
grandson's guitar case she also found
his journal in which he allegedly
described a desire to become infamous
writing quote I need to get the biggest
fatality number I possibly can on Monday
night Cathy O'Connor was confronted with
evidence her teenage grandson Joshua may
be planning a school shooting on Tuesday
morning she called 911 finding journal
entries from my grandson and he's
planning to have a mass shooting at one
of the high schools according to
authorities detectives searched Joshua's
house and seized a rifle bomb-making
equipment and his journal in it Joshua
allegedly wrote I'm preparing myself for
the school shooting I'm learning from
past shooters / bombers mistakes so I
don't make the same ones he boasted that
his aim was improving and wrote I can't
wait to walk into that class and blow
all those expletives away authorities
also say Joshua is the gunman in this
surveillance video of a convenience
store robbery Monday they say his rifle
matches the one used in the crime and
that his journal describes how he felt
powerful pointing the weapon at the
cashier he's required Wednesday a judge
deemed Joshua too dangerous to be
uncuffed during his arrest he slipped
his restraints and allegedly assaulted
an officer I'm sure she would have known
that this was going to get her grandson
into big-time trouble
Andy minds is with the school
district that oversees Joshua's high
school he thanked Joshua's grandmother
for making the call couldn't have been
an easy thing for her to do but boy was
sure the right thing for her to do
because that may have saved a lot of
lives
authorities believe O'Connor robbed the
convenience store for money to buy more
weapons for the attack his case is still
under investigation and he's currently
being held on a five million dollar bond
his public defender said in court that
her client has no criminal history
whatsoever but you can certainly
understand why the grandmother was so
concerned yeah and thank you Gretna
acted though that she saw the gun and
then did some more snooping good thank
you very much
thanks so much Tony